on sait que chaque fois qu'il ya un
confinement ces impacts à la fois les
ménages qui consomment beaucoup moins et
ça impacte aussi très nettement les
entreprises et le problème qui va se
passer avec cette cinquième vague c'est
que on a déjà ce phénomène mais on a en
plus le fait que la consommation des
ménages n'est pas revenu à son niveau de
la fin de 2019 fois sombre au niveau
globalement de 2019
à jack la reprise de la pandémie on
constate aujourd'hui en europe en europe
est ce qu'elle est de nature à
compromettre la croissance oui c'est une
éventualité qu'il faut avoir
effectivement à l'esprit parce que on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui elle a une
nouvelle vague ya ce qu'on appelle à la
cinquième vague que cette cinquième
vague elle commence à toucher toute une
série de pays il ya des pays qui ont
repris des mesures de confinement ou de
quasi confinement par exemple des couvre
feux et ça peut effectivement avoir un
impact plus ou moins important sur la
croissance et on voit bien d'ailleurs
que cette cinquième vague elle a
commencé plus tôt dans des pays qui ne
sont pas beaucoup vacciner assez les
pays de l'europe de l'est la bulgarie la
roumanie de là elle a progressé vers
l'ouest elle a touché l'autriche qui
d'ailleurs est le premier à un pays à
avoir re confiné elle touche l'allemagne
puis les pays-bas le danemark et
maintenant elle à elle touche la france
donc oui on voit bien justement cette
espèce de mouvement de la pandémie et en
même temps il faut quand même dire que
cette pandémie n'apparaît pas aussi
désastreuse que les premières parce que
vous voyez on a là sur le graphique le
chiffre des contaminations je dis bien
des contaminations et effectivement les
contaminations sont actuellement plus
importante que ce qu'elle était pendant
toute l'année 2000 21 et même pendant
l'année 2020 mais le nombre de gens qui
sont en hospitalisation et encore plus
en réanimation reste toujours beaucoup
plus faible et concrètement comment
est-ce que ça soit lens sur l'europe
alors
les conséquences si vous voulez ils sont
très liés aux mesures de confinement ou
de casey confinement comme les
couvre-feux on sait que chaque fois
qu'il ya un confinement ou
ou année au confinement et bien c'est un
pacte à la fois les ménages qui
consomment beaucoup moins et ça impacte
aussi très nettement les entreprises et
le problème qui va se passer avec cette
cinquième vague c'est que on a déjà ce
phénomène mais on a en plus le fait que
la consommation des ménages n'est pas
revenu à son niveau de la fin de 2019
fois sombre au niveau globalement de
2019 elle a chuté brutalement en 2020
bien sûr qu'elle est repartie en 2021
mais elle tend à se stabiliser
actuellement plutôt au niveau de 2014
2015 et on le voit d'ailleurs sur le
graphique qui apparaît à l'écran et donc
ça c'est un sujet de préoccupation pour
tous les économies parce que tout le
monde comprend que quand il ya moins de
consommation il ya moins d'activités
économiques et comment ça s'explique
concrètement alors l'une des
explications c'est très certainement
l'importance de l'épargné accumulée
alors vous savez que l'épargné accumulée
là on voit aussi le graphique au niveau
de la zone euro bon elle a été
spectaculaire en 2020 alors pour la zone
euro c'est pour l'ensemble des pays on
est passés grosso modo de 14 % de taux
départ à 21 % du pipe de taux dépargne
en france et bien on a vu que pendant
les confinements c'était 165 milliards
d'euros qui avait été épargnée ce que
l'on sait peut-être un petit peu moins
c'est que en même temps il y avait 30 %
des ménages qui n'avait pas épargné
qu'il y avait des épargnes et c'est la
pression de la pauvreté et que cette
épargne elle est très concentré sur les
10 % les plus riches sur le dernier
décile qui à lui seul en a fait 130
milliards alors qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire que les gens qui ont
surtout énormément épargnée ne sont pas
nécessairement très près ces deux
investir cet argent disons de leurs
dépenses et et on voit très bien ils ne
peuvent pas le dépenser actuellement les
voyages à l'étranger sont quand même
très restreint
il ya toute une série d'activités qui
commence à être restreinte si ce n'est
dans la loi du moins dans les faits par
exemple il ya beaucoup de restaurateurs
ou de gens qui organisent des événements
qui annonce des chutes de chiffre
d'affaires de 20 à 30% par rapport à ce
qu'il comptait faire pour noël donc il y
à bien aujourd'hui une forme de
contraction générale de la consommation
et de ce fait on va avoir une épargne
accumulée qui ne sert pas à grand chose
donc on a raison d'être inquiets pour la
croissance alors bien pour 2021 je ne
pense pas que ça aura beaucoup d'impact
un très sérieusement je pense que pour
2021 bon on fera peut-être pas les 6 7%
qui ont été prévu par l'insee mais on ne
devrait pas aller au delà d'un recul de
0 5% donc de passer à 6,2 pour cent pour
2022 c'est un autre problème parce que
même si la france ne connaît pas de
nouveaux reconfirme ans et il ya toute
une série de raisons d'abord le fait qu'
évidemment avec le vaccin peut-être
qu'on en aurait pas besoin et puis il ya
quand même une raison majeure c'est le
fait que nous allons avoir des élections
en 2022 donc même si la france ne
connaît pas de nouveau confinement et
bien si les confinements continuent de
se multiplier dans des pays voisins
autrement dit si l'activité des pays
voisins commencent à chuter de manière
importante par rapport à ces confinement
est d'ores et déjà on assiste à une
chute de la production industrielle qui
est non négligeable en allemagne et ce
qui est encore plus important c'est une
chute de la demande alors elle est pour
l'instant plutôt moins forte dans les
pays de l'union européenne et la chute
la plus importante c'est au niveau de la
non union européenne autrement dit du
reste du monde néanmoins ça veut dire
que il y à bien d'autres mécanismes qui
sont aussi en oeuvre et oui
effectivement on peut avoir quelques
inquiétudes sur le taux de croissance
que l'on connaîtra en deux 22 merci
jacques sapir pour votre édito
économique et la semaine prochaine ce
sera votre 100e et dit tout à fait écho
tout à fait